I think that some of what we call paranoia,
just normal paranoia is hypersensitivity and hyper awareness and awareness to a
lot of things that you're putting off in the back of your head.
Because in order to function as a normal person get through this life,
you can't really be aware of everything.
Otherwise you'd be paralyzed by fear.
We're in space.
Okay,
we are on a gigantic ball.
It's spinning a thousand miles an hour hurling through infinity.
This,
this is reality.
And take us out thin layer of gas.
It's protecting us from everything that's flying around in our solar system,
by the way,
a best to give you any five years and then it's all right.
And even if you make it to a hundred the last 15 talk shit,
we had the stem cells and stuff like that to timidity.
Yeah,
maybe to live to be 300 what do you do with the universe is infinite.
I like you're gonna die like the sun is going to end like at the end.
I mean,
imagine if people do live to an infinite number where we realized that fucking
son is dying.
You're going to freak out about that.
It's all relative,
right?
So there,
there's only so much you really can think about in some of what paranoia is,
is this hyper awareness of all these variables that you really haven't,
haven't considered.
And then also we were talking about before,
the things that can be beneficial to the hyper awareness of how you communicated
with people.
Maybe you've could have done a better job with that.
Maybe you,
you came in hot,
maybe you were upset about something else when you ran into them,
you already had a seven and they brought you to a 10 it was totally unnecessary.
Within a normal situation,
you would have only been at a too that those things are real and sometimes
marijuana helps highlight all the errors in your way.
I think it can be a tool,
but my description of it is like any other tool,
like a hammer,
you can build a house with a hammer or you could just hit yourself in the Dick
if you're fucking crazy.
And this,
this is something that I think we should consider when we're discussing almost
any psychedelic medicine.
And I think that,
I really do believe that marijuana is a psychedelic and I don't even think it's
a mild one,
especially when it's an edible form.
I don't think it's mild at all.
Yeah.
I mean there's some people that,
that come in to my office for example,
and like just when I meet them,
like after one or two minutes,
I was just,
I just got to decide in my head,
this person's not using THC like this.
This person is anxious with gives you that it was that what it is anxious.
Yeah.
It's just a feeling of um,
they're not really,
they're not someone who can just sit and kind of like be by themselves,
you know,
they just kind of give me the impression that,
um,
you know,
they're,
they're not going to do well with cannabis because if they have any type of
change in their,
um,
in their psyche,
they're going to see that as bad.
That's bad.
And like you got it when you're using cannabis,
you,
you have to be sewn and who,
who knows that okay.
Are going to get a little bit of maybe paranoid out,
or at least my psyche's going to change a little bit.
I am using,
you know,
psychoactive substance and not be able to freak out.
Right?
But some people,
um,
you know,
I know that if the youth a little bit of Thc,
they probably would have a freak out.
They probably would have a bad experience.
Generally,
it's people who are,
you know,
very,
very fearful.
Now the other side of that coin though is that if you CBD and like we discussed
earlier,
that can decrease learned fear,
right?
So,
so that,
so that's something that's,
that's really helpful for those patients.
But,
you know,
I do agree that,
um,
you know,
we have to be careful about using high THC in,
in certain groups of people.
For sure.